- I am just getting back
from the Apple Event
and I had such an awesome time,
and thank you guys so
much for subscribing.
I also just hit six million subscribers,
so this has been a really
awesome and a crazy week,
and I could not do it without you guys.
So a huge thank you to
everybody who followed along
on this iPhone journey and
adventure this past week.
And I cannot wait because the
iPhone and the Apple Watch,
it'll all be here before we know it.
So now that I'm back, I've
had a little bit of time
to decompress and think about the Event.
The main highlights, of
course, in case you did miss it
is they announced three new iPhones.
There is the iPhone 11 which
comes in five different colors.
And the iPhone Pro and the iPhone Pro Max.
The iPhone Pro comes in four colors now,
a silver, a gold, and a Space Gray,
and this new color which
is a Midnight Green.
And seeing the Midnight Green in person
was actually really cool,
because the color that they
showed during the keynote,
it was kind of like a muted
color, sort of washed out.
But when you see it in person,
every single time that
I've moved it around
in different lighting, it
always looks different.
And I really actually
like the color a lot.
Although for me personally,
even though it's not Friday yet,
I haven't done my pre-orders,
I think I'm gonna go with the silver
because I did order the
white ceramic watch,
so I would like for my
phone and watch to match.
The main difference
between the iPhone 11 Pro
and the regular iPhone 11 is
the cameras and the display.
So the iPhone 11 has an LCD display,
whereas the iPhone Pro has a
Super Retina OLED XDR display.
There was some crazy long
term that they called it.
The iPhone 11 also only has two cameras.
Only, it's like, okay,
it only has two cameras?
It has two cameras because
the XR still only had one,
so this is an addition and an upgrade.
The iPhone Pro has three cameras.
It has an ultra-wide telephoto
and a wide-angle lens.
And the front-facing does 4K.
It's also been bumped up to 12 megapixels,
so you're definitely
getting better photos.
You're also able to do
slo-mo video front-facing.
And I do shoot a lot of front-facing video
when I'm vlogging.
So the Pro's three cameras
are the ultra-wide,
the wide, and the telephoto lens.
So being able to have those three cameras
gives you a lot more
flexibility when you're filming.
And it's cool because
when you are filming,
you'll still be able to
see the outside frame
of whatever else would
potentially be in-frame
if you switched lenses.
So that's something that a lot of
these other phones don't do.
They may have these multiple cameras,
but they're not really using
them all at the same time.
And that brings us to FiLMiC Pro.
I've used this app before,
but it's kind of something
that really lets you take
advantage of your iPhone camera.
But this new version of FiLMiC Pro,
you are able to see all of
your cameras at the same time.
And this is really cool,
because that's something
that I've never seen before.
And something that I think is gonna be fun
for vloggers and content creators,
you'll be able to film using
two of those angles at the same time.
So if I want to film a
front-facing but also
a rear-facing camera at
the same time, you can.
So I can't wait to try that out.
I'm not sure when the
release of the new FiLMiC pro
will be out, but when it is,
I'll definitely be doing some
extensive coverage of that.
The introduction of the new ultra-wide
is something that is not new,
that we've seen that in
films before and it has been
something that I've been
really wanting on the iPhone.
He also talked about this
new Deep Fusion photography,
which is like a computational math,
scientific, mad scientist.
I don't remember his exact precise words.
So it's basically using AI
to generate a more detailed photo.
So that will be a software
update later this year.
But I can probably sit here
and talk for the next like
five hours about everything
that they discussed.
I just wanted to do a quick little recap,
and this doesn't seem
to be so quick, is it?
Being able to shoot in the
ultra-wide is gonna be so fun
for video and vlogging, and
doing landscape photography.
So I cannot wait to get
my hands on this thing
and really test it out.
I think the big question
for a lot of people is
do I need to spend the
extra money to get the Pro,
or will I be perfectly happy with the 11?
Do I need to upgrade if I have a XS?
Do I need to upgrade if I have a X?
I think really I would
just encourage you to go to
the Apple store if you are
on the fence and test it out.
Do the photos look different than
the phone that you already have?
Is this something that is going to make
a huge difference in your life?
Is this something that you
have the extra money to spend?
If you are a content creator,
I definitely think that it is
something that you should consider,
because a lot of the stuff
is investing in your future,
in your career, and in
your content creation.
They also announced a new iPad
which I tested out at the event.
And I was playing Apple Arcade on it
and I'm kind of really
excited about Apple Arcade,
mostly because it is
something that you can play
across all platforms.
You can play on your phone,
you can play on your iPad,
you can play on Apple TV,
you can play on your Mac.
Like, it's really cool how
this is all just integrated
into the Apple ecosystem.
And it's also really
cool because you can use
a controller, yes, a
freaking Xbox controller,
or a Playstation controller
on your Apple TV,
or on your Mac, or on
your phone, or your iPad.
That is something that I never
thought in a million years
would ever happen, and when
they announced that at WWDC
I was like, yeah, that's cool.
So Apple Arcade is 4.99 and
also, Apple TV+ is 4.99.
I thought that they would announce
some sort of a bundling service,
but I feel like maybe later
on down the line they will.
But both of those prices was way less
than I thought it was gonna be.
But that also could be is
they wanna keep those costs
a little bit lower because
if you do buy an iPad
or an iPhone, you're gonna
want things to do on it.
So keeping you in that ecosystem
and keeping those prices down,
I feel like more people
will have access to it
and be willing to spend
those extra dollars.
But the good news is they said
that you will get a year free
when you buy a new iPhone
or an iPad or a Mac,
or anything like that.
So that is a nice little added bonus.
They also announced an
Apple Watch Series 5,
which I was very excited.
I kinda didn't think they were going to.
I'm not sure why I thought they weren't.
But it doesn't matter what
I thought because they did.
They announced a few
different new watch faces.
They have a new titanium, and
also a brushed black titanium.
They have a new ceramic which
is the one that I ordered,
and I can't wait.
'Cause they obviously
have the cellular and GPS
in the aluminum versions.
They have some new Nike ones.
They have a new Hermes black
band, which is so cool.
It looks amazing.
But yeah, I went back to the ceramic.
I had the ceramic years
ago and it still is just
my favorite look, especially
if I get the silver phone.
They're gonna match perfectly,
and I just, (breathes deeply)
I said I can't wait because I,
well, I guess I have to
wait, I don't have a choice.
But either way, it's
gonna be here so soon.
I would love to hear
from you guys, though.
What did you think of the Event?
Which phone was your favorite?
Are you going to upgrade?
Are you not gonna upgrade?
Leave me all of those comments below
and I'll be chatting with
you guys in the Comments.
So we've got new phones on the
way, we've got new watches.
We got a new iPad.
We have Apple TV, we have Apple Arcade.
I'm trying to think if there's
anything that I'm missing.
I probably should've took
some notes, but I didn't.
Anyway, we're back on the
white wall for iPhone season.
I just wanted to kinda give
it a nice little throwback,
especially for the six
million sub milestone.
A lot of you guys said you
guys missed the white wall,
so I thought let's
bring it back for a bit.
There will be plenty more
iPhone and Apple Watch
and Apple content coming up this month,
so make sure you guys are subscribed.
And I will see you soon.
Make sure you're following me
on Twitter and Instagram too.
'Cause if you're not, I'm gonna be sad.